it's a long way from home and there's no
easy way to get this beluga whale back
to where he belongs he strayed into the
river sane and a swam nearly halfway to
Paris 80 kilometers up River now
officials have decided the best way of
saving the huge mammal is to move it to
a saltwater tank but it'll be a
challenging operation
if someone among you has an idea how to
transport a beluga weighing 800 to 900
kilos 4 meters long without putting it
in danger because danger is real we're
all very aware of it there is a real
risk in transporting it and we're doing
everything to ensure that we don't
endanger its life maybe it won't work
but at least we will have tried our best
the whale is being held in a lock Basin
where vets have administered vitamins
and antibiotics he had been refusing to
eat
we've been observing his behavior and
notice he's a bit stressed but what is
reassuring is that he is managing his
stress and has been relatively calm he
prefers the side of the lock where there
is less noise
the nearest Beluga population is nearly
3 000 kilometers away north of Norway
scientists hope that by building up his
strength in a closely monitored tank
this whale will be better prepared for
the very long swim home
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera